nous sommes en guerre
et nous allons tout anéantir
les champions ne se royaume ne pourront
rien contre nous
vous êtes vachement effrayante ça j'ai
pas honte de le reconnaître
[Musique]
changement ces dernières années ma
sorcier m'a doté de super pouvoir
sauf que tous les autres en ont
maintenant poursuite
des enfants se sont emparés du pouvoir
de tous les quiches
ils l'ont arraché autrefois de notre
père
non
voir mon enfant ton monde
les chercher
le monde
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre ces
pouvoirs
j'arriverai pas ta carte prendre mes
pouvoirs tu me les a donné alors tu peux
me les reprendre
j'ai cherché un être méritant d'être
champion
tu sais exactement ce qu'il faut faire
qu'est-ce que tu fais je dois aller
jusqu'au bout maintenant
c'est
[Musique]